well I've been away on vacation this
week and I'm actually going on vacation
again a week from now so what I'm gonna
do is I'm just gonna take a vacation
every other week in perpetuity well that
would be nice anyway I'd love if I could
do that now we decided we decided to
take our two weeks this this way to two
weeks of vacation but breaking it up in
this weird way for some reason we were
at a lake in Pennsylvania this week and
then in two weeks were gonna be at a
lake in New England so we enjoy lakes
and as part of our fascination with
lakes I have developed a bit of a
fascination with with with fishing an
interest in fishing anyway the problem
though is that my interest in fishing
does not include so far a corresponding
talent for fishing so when I say that I
that I've been fishing I've been fishing
all this week but when I say I've been
fishing all this week what I really mean
is I've been casting hooks into the
water I don't mean that I've been
catching fish all this week but that's
really this is what I've discovered when
it comes to developing a hobby is that
in the early going and this is why I
think a lot of people have trouble
developing obviously why I do as well is
that in the early going you have to
enjoy the hobby while being terrible at
it and it's it's hard to like something
when you're bad at it but if you could
push through that phase then eventually
I think the payoff comes so maybe
I'm about two years into it I'm still
waiting for that payoff anyway I didn't
have my phone on this this this week I
didn't check the news at all I avoided
all that like the plague so I have
therefore missed most of the discussion
over the separation of families at the
borders by the time I got back back
Trump had already effectively reversed
the policy at least to the extent that
he could legally but I do want to say
just one quick thing on this because I
haven't really chimed in on the issue
yet I know that the whole world has been
waiting with bated breath to hear what I
have to say about it
nobody cares I know you don't have to
remind here's here's what I think about
if we are going to enforce our laws and
protect our border and I think we should
do both of those things
then there has to be some kind of legal
penalty for those who break our law and
sneak across the board and if we're
going to prosecute them and send them
back which is the penalty at least in
the for the first time across it's a
misdemeanor so you prosecute them send
it back if they come back again then
it's a felony so if we're gonna go
through that whole process then then we
have to detain them in the meanwhile we
have to lock them somewhere keep them
somewhere while that process of
prosecution and then eventually shipping
them back is is carried out if we don't
then they're just gonna disappear into
the ether and we'll never see them again
so we can't we can't say to them oh
you're in trouble now mister you snuck
across the border so just go do what you
want but check back in two weeks there's
gonna be a court case and here you go
here's a here's appears a note okay
here's your court date come back make
sure you check but in fact you know what
I want you every three days I want you
to give us a call just to check in all
right honor system
don't don't disappoint us by
disappearing like everybody else now we
can't do that if we do that then it's
just there's no point we're never going
to see them so you see how the there's
kind of a logical progression here
where if we're starting with the
proposition that it is good to enforce
our laws and protect our border
that I don't see how we avoid you know
you follow down once we get like two or
three steps into it we are inevitably
going to get to the point where we have
to detain confine lock up these people
for a period of time I don't see how you
avoid that I don't see any way around it
the only other option as far as I can
tell is to not enforce the law or to
enforce it in a way that is so
incompetent and ineffective that you may
as well not enforce it and if an illegal
alien family
if an illegal alien family comes across
and they claim asylum then there's still
the same the same issue where that
asylum claim has to be investigated in
processed and in the meanwhile you've
got to detain them somewhere because
claiming asylum is not just they say oh
I claim asylum and we say okay you're
good then because if that was the
process then everybody would claim
asylum and it would be anarchy
but Asylum is a very particular thing
for a very particular situation it's not
for everybody
so that's that's the issue
and if we are going to detain them and
if we have an entire family and we've
got thousands of entire families that
are streaming across the border all the
time we catch an entire family with
parents kids everything else and we're
going to confine all of them while we go
through this process that we run into
some complications first of all we run
into all the different laws that govern
the detainment of families we also run
into the fact that there is a different
process for parents or for adults than
than there is for kids so there are all
these kinds of bureaucratic loopholes
and complications
and I'm all about streamlining that and
taking the bureaucracy out of some of
this stuff and making it simpler I'm all
I'm all about doing that in every facet
of of American life especially when it
comes to immigration so if that's what
we're gonna do I say great and then
there's also an issue of resources and
capabilities we do not have infinite
resources and an infinite capability to
detain and care for and provide for an
entire families all at once
but if it were possible legally speaking
and in terms of resources capabilities
logistics laws everything else all the
things you got to take into
consideration if it were possible to
detain entire families together I would
be in favor of that I would think that's
the best approach I'm not a fan of
separating kids from their parents but I
don't like that I don't like the idea of
separating kids I don't like the idea of
kids being traumatized and and and so
forth especially when you consider that
because this is a bureaucracy we're
talking about bureaucracies are very
clumsy bureaucracies are very
inefficient ineffective so there's also
the difficulty of reuniting the families
after the kids have been separated so I
don't like any of that and I'll fully
admit when I'm a sucker when it comes to
two things involving kids you know III
don't like the idea of kids being upset
traumatized separated from their parents
I mean I hate that because I think about
my own kids I think about like my
five-year-old kids being separated from
us so I'm like most people when it comes
to that I look at that and I say now
look if we could figure out another way
let's do it but the other way cannot be
just not enforcing the law the other way
cannot be oh you have a kid with you
well then just well just do what you
want to throw open the doors to anyone
who happens to wander across the border
with kids
because then you have the situation
we're facing right now which is kids are
used as get out you'll get across the
border free cards they're they're used
that way and I think that that is much
more dehumanizing than detaining them
so that is a that situation is bad for
our country it's also bad for the kids
so it's also in the kids best interest
for us to enforce our laws and to have
this disincentive
to make it to make it clear to people
it's a it's a bad idea
to bring your kids across the border
illegally we want to disincentivize that
we want there to be a deterrent so
that's what we're at
you got a detain that we got to enforce
the laws got to detain them
we don't want to separate them yeah but
we have to enforce the law so the only
other option if it's possible is the
keys detain the families altogether but
even that is not a clean or easy
solution keeping an entire family
detained it is still upsetting to a lot
of people just as we've seen because
even even after Trump even after Trump
reversed himself on this said they're
gonna change the policy he's still being
criticized by the media and by the left
because they're saying well it's not
good enough because even if you detain
the families you can find the families
together
you're still confining kids and
confining families and that's bad we
can't do that
so what they're really trying to get to
is let's not enforce our laws it's they
don't have a problem necessarily
specifically with separating kids they
have a problem with us enforcing the law
so that's what this discussion is really
about
and here's the reality that you run
right into when we're talking about this
that there is not always a nice or
polite way to maintain and protect a
civilization if we are going to have a
civilization if we're going to have a
country then we have to enforce our laws
and that as I've established is is going
to involve catching the people when
they're coming across confining them in
some sort of locked environment okay and
then prosecuting them and shipping them
back that has to be the process
we that's the only way we can have a
country and a civilization and it's not
polite it's not nice it doesn't you know
it's it's it's somewhat unpleasant
not always nice polite and pleasant ways
to maintain a civilization
we have this really childish ridiculous
idea this utopian idea that we can just
erase the borders and get rid of all the
laws and just say everybody live where
you want do what you want it's fine
everything is fine you know you values
people that grew up listening to that
stupid horrible John Lennon's song
imagine you know imagine a world without
borders without countries and so forth
which is just people with the mentality
of five-year-olds who think that sounds
like a good idea you know in fact I had
and also the other problem you have a
lot of people have never read a history
book and really know nothing about the
world whatsoever for instance yesterday
on Twitter someone said to me and I know
you've heard this a million times I'm
sure you have as well
somebody told me on Twitter the other
day they said yesterday they said well
America was founded on open borders
America was founded on open borders
which that's not that's literally
impossible you you cannot found a
country with open borders because
founding a country with open borders
means you're not founding any country at
all the process of establishing and
founding a country means drawing a
border
and probably fighting over it that isn't
as an essential component of founding a
country is the border that's what
defines it it's like building a house
Sykes it's like saying you know I built
my house without walls well then you
didn't build a house that's not a house
you're just living on on a mattress in
the grass okay that's not a house
building a house means building the
walls
there's no such thing as a house without
walls
um
in fact when you look at the the history
the early history of the United States
when you look at the 18th and 19th
century of your history of the United
States what you find is an endless
series of wars battles and other armed
conflicts that were fought in order to
define establish maintained found and
expand our borders that's what you find
you find men who are willing to fight
and bleed to defend establish define
expand the borders that's what you find
here and that's what you find everywhere
in the world in every civilization there
has never been a civilization that
established itself it established its
borders by talking politely and nicely
to the civilizations around it and
saying say do you mind if we draw our
borders here oh yeah sure you could draw
you know what effect its effect you
don't have some of Ireland you could
draw a little bit further back here and
then have some of ours and oh yeah be
our guest are you absolutely and then
they all shake hands and they have tea
and crumpets together no that's that's
that's never happened it is a bloody it
is a bloody rough thing I and and it's
it's that isn't unavoidable
now that doesn't mean it's this is not
an end justify the means situation
that doesn't mean that everything a
country does in order to protect define
its borders is justified we should still
strive to be humane and just
while we set out to do that
and that should be one of the things
that separates America from other
countries is that we care about being
humane and just but you can you can do
something that's humane and just and yet
at the same time is kind of upsetting
and unpleasant that's what I think a lot
of people miss so just because it's
upsetting and just because it makes you
feel icky inside and just because it's
unpleasant doesn't mean that it's
inhumane and it doesn't mean that it's
unjust
I mean the idea of enforcing any law is
kind of unpleasant the idea of locking
anyone in prison for breaking a law
that's it it's an unpleasant idea I mean
I doesn't make me feel good when I think
about people in prison even when I think
about a murder in prison is it's it's
it's not like it fills me with with just
happy butterflies in my stomach I'm just
so happy thinking about people locked in
prison it's not it's not a happy
pleasant thing but it's a necessary and
just and humane thing and it's also fair
here's the other thing enforcing our law
is it's nothing personal against these
people who are coming across the border
illegally
and yeah you know what if I lived in
some dirt poor drug infested Central
American country and I had kids
especially and I couldn't really speak
English and I didn't understand the
American system and I didn't even know
how to go about obtaining legal American
citizenship and I had heard all these
stories about how difficult it is and
everything else and then I'd also heard
stories about how easy it is to just
sneak across the border and I've already
got family somewhere and you know Texas
or whatever then then if I were in that
situation I may well decide to sneak
across the border myself I don't know I
may make that situation because I would
be far far more concerned with
protecting my children than with obeying
the law
so I get it I understand on a personal
level I understand and I sympathize
you can sympathize with someone and yet
still believe that they should face the
penalties for breaking the law
look I sympathize with people who grow
up in the gutter you know in in in the
inner city and they have no parental
guidance to speak of they're just
surrounded by gangs and violence and
drugs all the time it's there's there's
no moral family formation no guidance
nothing and and they start selling drugs
when they're 12 years old and by the
time they're 18 they're you know
knocking over liquor stores I sympathize
with those people and I look at the
situation that they're in and the way
that they're the trajectory that they've
been on and I think I could very easily
have ended up doing the same thing if I
was in their situation but we still have
to enforce the law so we still have to
lock them in jail because the law
matters the law must still be enforced
it's nothing personal it doesn't mean
that we hate you it doesn't mean that
you're dirt it doesn't mean that we're
dehumanizing somebody it just means that
the law must be enforced so these
families are doing what they think they
need to do
and we as a country have to do what we
must do
oh that's a lot of life you know but
that's that's what life consists of a
lot of times is you have two people with
competing interests who are both doing
or two groups doing what they think they
need to do
and then there's kind of a clash there
we can't have a country if we don't have
a border that's what this really comes
down
and enforcing the border is can be an
unpleasant process you have to be able
to remove emotions from law now that
doesn't mean you remove morality from
law it doesn't mean you remove justice
from law it doesn't mean you remove
humanity from law it doesn't mean you
remove fairness from law but you do have
to remove emotion laws should be just
humane affair but they can't always be
comfortable they can't always be nice
and they can't always be pleasant and in
order to have justice in order to have
order in order to have a civilization
you have to have just fair clear
understandable laws that are enforced
and it's going to be as I said
unpleasant
no matter how you do it and I'm ok if we
can keep the kid the families together I
say let's do that but we still have to
detain them and they still have to face
the penalty
and even that even if we get rid of all
the situations where kids are being
separated keep the families together but
still we still are running in to the to
the to the fact that we're gonna be we
have to catch these people confine them
go through this legal process and then
send them back across the border to a
country that is not a very nice place to
live they're trying to escape it and in
the meanwhile there's gonna be tears and
there's going to be you know there's
gonna be some some some level of trauma
and people's dreams are gonna be crushed
I mean they were dreaming of of living
in America and escaping all of this and
that's now being taken from them I mean
that's an unpleasant tough thing to
think about it really is it doesn't make
me happy to think about but it is
necessary and it is just
because it is the law and it is a
necessary just fair law the kind of law
that every country has and must have or
it cannot be a country
um
the real problem is that many of the
people who are shouting about the child
separation issue what they when it
really comes down to us they don't want
to enforce the law at all they want open
borders so they are not looking for a
more just a more fair a more humane way
to enforce the law that would be a
worthy discussion okay if that's what we
were talking about if we were just
talking about well what is the the best
way to enforce this law this necessary
law that that you know protects our
border if we were having that discussion
I'm saying that's a great that's a great
discussion a very productive very
fruitful very important but that's not
the discussion
instead we're having a discussion about
immigration law with people who don't
think there should be any immigration
laws
so it'd be the same thing if we were
talking about you know what what are the
the most humane ways to deal with
prisoners in the prison system
but it turns out that half of the people
involved in the discussion think that
there should be no prisons at all well
then you can't get anywhere in the
conversation
because number one they're really being
disingenuous
I mean that there they're beginning the
conversation by criticizing this
particular policy but then it turns out
that they don't think there should be
any policies so that's disingenuous and
it's also incoherent the open borders
position is incoherent because it means
the dissolution of our country
and in the process it means dissolving
the very thing that makes our country
appealing to those people in Mexico and
Central America and South America
so
if there's a way to keep these families
together while you enforce the law and
protect the border then let's do that
I don't want to see kids separate from
their families out of Lexi
but we cannot what we cannot do is go
back to a policy where anyone who
crosses the border with a child even if
the child doesn't even started belong to
them gets to come in scot-free you know
we cannot go back to that we cannot do
that
that's not good for the kids it's not
good for the country it's not good for
anybody
except maybe smugglers who profit off
this whole situation
so if you want to talk about enforcing
law humanely great but enforcing the law
here's the first part of that
and we have to do it even if makes our
tummies hurt we still have to do it
alright thanks for listening everybody
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
next week have a great weekend Godspeed